So in this case, first question
to ask is if we are trying to
come up with a constraint for
this operation, what's its context?
>> It is the patron class.
>> So it's in the patron class with
constraints that talk about operations.
We can go a step further and
say which operations.
So, we're going to essentially
have Patron, and in this case,
there's going to be double colon,
separating Patron from the name
of the particular operation.
And we're allowed to go one step further
and actually have the signature there.
Now the signature was expressed within
just the UML diagram part of things.
So to fill in this part of the
constraint, we're going to say context.
We're going to have a patron colon,
colon.
And then the items
currently checked out.
And in this case there's no arguments or
at least there's no explicit argument.
In object-oriented languages there's
always an implicit argument of
the object receiving the request.
>> So the Patron itself.
>> So
the Patron itself is an argument and
we're going to qualify
with respect to it.
And so there's no explicit
argument listed in the signature,
however there is a return value.
Given the diagram,
what do you think would be the type
of the return value of
this CheckedOut operation?
>> It would be a LoanableItem.
>> Okay, but the requirement
says the LoanableItems, plural.
>> Well, okay, yeah, so a list or
some group of some LoanableItems.
>> Okay.
>> Where that association becomes,
when you actually program it in.
>> Okay, in this case because there's
a plural in the expression of things,
we know there's going
to be more than one.
And OCL provides us various,
what it calls collection classes,
ways of organizing things.
And it's important in deciding
exactly which collection class to use,
to think about the properties
that are required.
So I use the word list and
list tends to have an order.
In this case do we care about the order?
>> Not particularly, I don't think.
>> Okay, so what other data structure
is a collection class but
doesn't care about order?
>> A set or an array or?
>> So OCL does have a set operation,
so in this case the return value for
this operation is a set
of loanable items.
>> Is it okay,
because when you use the word set,
it makes me think that you're implying
we can only check out one of a certain
type of book which may be a requirement,
but
I don't think that was explicit
in the requirements statement.
You can check out multiple copies
of the same book, couldn't you?
>> There's nothing about either
the requirements or this
OCL that prevents you from checking
out multiple copies of the same book,
because each of those is going
to be a separate loanable item.
>> Okay so-
>> But
what it is preventing you from
doing is checking out the same book
twice at the same time.
>> Right, that's what I mean.
>> Right.
>> So we can't do that, even.
Is that specified in the requirements,
or is that just something we're now
implying-
>> Okay, so great point.
So we call one of the subtleties of
the original requirements analysis had
to do with what happens if you
check out a book, hold it overdue,
you have money due on it, you return
it so it's not accruing any extra
as far as the fine is concerned, but
the system has to remember that, right?
So in a sense that CheckedOut
record has to still be there
to hold that information.
Now what happens if you
try to check it out again?
If we use a set here
we run the risk of clobbering
the record and breaking things.
So I think you've pointed out
a place where we have to be very,
very careful about doing this right.
And in this case it looks like yes,
we would clobber things in
that particular situation.
For operations that we're
trying to model in OCL,
the next question typically is
what are the preconditions.
And that means the circumstances
under which it is meaningful for
the operation to execute.
In the case of items
currently checked out,
as with most operations
that provide a value
without affecting any change in
state there are no preconditions.
In OCL we have two ways
of dealing with that.
We could have a precondition
which has the Boolean value
true which says it always is the case
that it's okay to run this operation.
Or we can leave out
the precondition entirely
which has the same implications.
And so for readability purposes
you may want to do that to make
the overall constraint a little shorter.
The third part in specifying
operations is to specify
which value is returned
by the operation.
To compute the items that are currently
checked out, we merely navigate along
the CheckedOut association to
the corresponding loanable items.
So here's what the overall
constraint looks like.
We have the context which
had our signature, and
then we had a post condition.
And now the post condition lists
another OCL keyword, which is result.
And that stands in for whatever it is
that's computed by that operation.
And what needs to be computed
in this case is those
links in the CheckedOut association
which correspond to items checked
out by this particular patron.
Now we already are restricted by
our context to just the patron
of interest for the query.
And that patron is then
going to be a partner in
certain of the links in the association
and we want to get the partners at
the other end, the loanable items
that belong to that patron.
So we navigate from Patron,
which is our context,
through CheckedOut to LoanableItem,
and that will be the set of loanable
items that are currently
associated with that patron.
It once again leave us in the situation,
what does checked out mean?
It means either you currently have them
checked out, and haven't returned them.
Or you checked them out, you held
them too long, you returned them, and
the system is remembering that
you still owe something on them.